Ouais, on est chez les parents de Faustine.
Beh non, ils sont pas là.
Pourquoi ?
Et du coup tu sors pas toi, Ju ? Ce soir ?
Mmmmh ?
Tu sors pas ce soir ?
Non. Plus de thune. Mes couilles.
Genre plus de thune.
Tu veux voir mon compte en banque toi ?
Mais genre, c'est ça qui va t'empêcher de sortir, t'sais.
Et beh si tu me rinces la gueule, moi je suis ok hein.
Et beh si c'était le seul problème mon gars...
Non, commence pas.
Okay, c'est quoi le problème là ?
Non mais t'inquiète, t'inquiète, ton frère il sait très bien de quoi je parle, c'est bien.
Bah non c’est pas bien ! Moi je veux savoir. C’est quoi ?
C'est bon, ta pote elle ouvre sa gueule, elle est contente, super.
Et beh assume devant ta soeur, trou du quare.
Bon il y a quoi là ? C'est quoi ?
Et beh vas-y, dis-lui !
Insupportable ! T'es insupportable !
Mais elle veut entendre ton histoire, elle veut comprendre pourquoi tu veux pas sortir.
Julien, dis-moi ! C'est quoi ?
C'est de la merde, nul ! On passe !
C'est toi la grosse merde.
Julien ! Dis-moi !
J'ai voulu pécho une meuf, hier soir, je me suis foiré ok ?
C'est avant que tu rentres de ton date de merde là.
Et donc ouais, le lundi soir... Le mardi soir aussi...
Le mardi soir ?
Ouais le mardi soir je viens, et euh...
Non, pardon. Excuse-moi, j'ai vraiment pas envie de ça.
Je suis avec toutes mes potes là.
Ouais je t'excuse, ouais...
Non mais on sort, on discute, là c'est cool...
C'est super, tu te fous de ma gueule, c'est ça qui est top !
Excuse-moi si je t'ai fait croire quoi que ce soit, juste...
Non, non, c'est pas ça. C'est juste que ça fait 2h que tu joues avec mes couilles et là tu assumes pas.
Je t'attends tout à l'heure hein ! Mon con !
T'es sérieux là, de parler comme ça, je joue avec tes couilles ?
Non mais c'est... Et tes enculés de potes qui se foutent de ma gueule, c'est génial...
Wouah, attends, attends, t'es en train de parler de mes potes comme ça ?
"Attends, attends, t'es en train de parler de mes potes comme ça ?"
C'est pas mec, c'est Julien, va baiser tes potes maintenant, casse-toi ! S'il-te-plaît !
Beh alors tu sais quoi, mon grand, je vais aller les baiser mes potes,
Je vais bien les baiser mes potes, et toi tu vas rester tout seul avec ta toute petite queue entre les jambes.
"Ma toute petite queue..." Articule déjà et ma queue elle est très bien, allez ! Casse-toi s'il-te-plaît !
Tranquille, merci.
Ouais je me casse connard.
Souvent quand on a raison on se barre ?
Tu sais quoi, tu sais pas qui je suis, tu regretteras de ne pas m'avoir roulé une pelle.
Chipie des bois. Va.
Petit cul !
C'est toi qui parles mal à ma pote ?
Alors de une, je te connais pas, et de deux t'as très mauvaise haleine.
C'était Salomé.
Salomé Salomé ?
La goudou !
Mais elle est pas goudou.
Bien sûr que si, elle est goudou.
Mais non elle est pas goudou, elle touche à tout, elle me parle toujours de mecs, elle est pas que goudou.
Elle est bi, ok.
Non mais le truc, Faustine, c'est que ton frère il est mauvais.
Mais arrêtez, petit bichon.
Mais il y a pas de petit bichon !
Avec son téléphone là, ses phrases toutes pétées qu'il sort.
Son regard qui pue le quare au bout du troisième verre.
Indigne ! Indigne ! Un bouffon quoi.
Un vrai bouffon.
Un professionnel.
Un pauvre type.
Une pauvre grosse merde.
Non c'est bon, stop ! On a compris !
Julien, t'as dit ça ?
Oui, je me suis foiré.
Mais putain mais t'es naze.
Ça va, je me suis excusé, elle va s'en remettre.
Je suis pas non plus le plus gros des connards.
C'était maladroit, mais c'était pas méchant.
C'était maladroit.
Ok. Lève-toi.
Lève-toi ! Assa viens !
Lève-toi je te dis !
Non.
Lève-toi ! Fais-moi confiance, vas-y.
Ok... Euh... Impro ! Donc on imagine qu'on est en terrasse toutes les trois.
Ça fait une heure que tu regardes Assa et que t'as pour projet de la choper.
Tu veux vraiment jouer, là maintenant sûr ?
Oui vas-y fais-moi confiance.
Attends mais... Genre lui il va me draguer là...
Mais MDR, Julien le tombeur, askip !
Mais oui, ça fait une heure que tu l'as remarquée, qu'elle t'a remarqué, donc tu viens vers elle et t'abordes la conversation.
Ok.
Salut, tu veux bien boire un verre avec moi ?
Salut, ouais je veux bien boire un verre avec toi.
Non mais Assa, s'il-te-plaît ! Les filles.
Non mais Julien, Julien c'est bien. Par contre tu peux pas lui parler comme ça. Il faut que tu sois plus subtil.
Plus subtil ?
Ouais.
Mais tu comprends le mot subtil ? Tête de sandale ou pas ?
Zoé arrête !
Non mais sérieusement c’est pas compliqué bordel. Ça fait une heure que t'es au bar, tu es avec des potes là, tu fais le mec. Merde !
Je fais le mec ou je...
Oui, genre, vous vous regardez depuis une heure, un coup c'est toi, un coup c'est elle et vos regards se croisent alors tu viens vers elle.
Ouais comme hier Ju avant que tu sombres.
Voilà, donc tu arrives vers elle, les épaules voilà...
Et t'attaques.
Ah non, mais par contre il faut pas lui parler comme ça à lui.
Non mais t'attaques pas mais... T'es bien, tu vois, troisième verre. T'es détendu, tu mates la fille, la fille te mate.
Donc quelque part c'est acté. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Oh ! T'es avec moi ?
Genre c'est bon ? C'est dans la poche ?
Non c'est pas bon non...
Non c'est pas bon... Ok.
Ça peut le devenir. D'accord ? Hé vous vous matez depuis tout à l'heure, donc il y a une attirance physique.
Maintenant il faut aller lui parler.
Vas-y Julien.
Ok bon hé Julien ! Les épaules droites ! Hop ! Tu te tiens droit !
Et le sourire, c'est important, c'est le premier signe de confiance en soi.
T'es beau Julien ! D'accord ?
C'est vrai ?
Non ferme ta gueule et joue !
Recommence.
Ok.
Alors...
Salut, on se regarde depuis tout à l'heure, est-ce que ça te tenterait de boire un verre avec moi ?
Assa !
Non franchement, en vrai, c'est pas mal.
C'est pas mal du tout ! Mais je pense, qu'il faut que tu regardes mes potes si on veut que ça marche.
Mais c'est ça que je comprends pas, en fait... Si je te veux toi, pourquoi j'irais regarder ? Je m'en fous de vous en fait.
Et beh voilà, on y vient, il comprend rien.
Regarde, réfléchis. Je suis bien là moi, avec mes copines.
Ok on se regarde, mais tu penses que ça va être simple pour être seul avec moi ?
Non, il faut que j'ai l'approbation de mes potes.
Il faut qu'on sente toutes les trois que t'es un mec bien, en plus d'être beau.
T'as juste à les considérer un peu.
Juste à regarder qu'elles passent et elles seront plus de mèche avec toi.
Et beh belle leçon de liberté Mesdames, top !
Mais non mais Assa, elle a raison,
Tu viens vers nous, tu nous regardes, tu nous considères, et après tu regardes Assa, tu restes focus sur Assa.
Ok, j'arrive...
Je vous regarde. Je vous considère, vous deux, en tant qu'individus féminins individuels.
Je me tourne vers votre amie,
Salut !
Je te regarde depuis tout à l'heure, et j'aimerais beaucoup t'inviter à boire un verre, est-ce que ça te tente ?
Ok ! Ok ! Le regard est top !
Ouais j'ai senti.
C'est bien par contre la phrase d'accroche, elle est naze.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que... Il faut pas que tu... Tu...
Ok bon, Julien.
En imaginant que t'es bien habillé, d'accord ?
Ambiancé avec tes potes.
Que je suis beau ?
Ferme ta gueule ! Ferme ta gueule !
Ok.
En imaginant que t'es bien habillé, ambiancé avec tes potes, d'accord ?
Que vous vous regardez depuis une heure, donc là tu fais le mec t'arrives,
Tu nous prends, Faustine et moi en considération et là il faut que tu sortes the réplique.
Ouais mais the réplique je l'ai bien faite juste avant, alors qu'est-ce que...
Ouais c'était bien...
Non ! J'sais pas ! T'arrives tu lui dis :
Beh salut, on se téma depuis tout à l'heure.
On prendrait pas un verre ensemble ?
Grave ! Ça c'est bien ! Tu vois !
Et beh évidemment que c'est bien. Le mec il dit ça, forcément moi je dis oui.
Ah oui ?
Normalement ?
Je vous regarde...
Je te regarde...
Salut...
On se regarde depuis tout à l'heure, il faut qu'on arrête de se mentir on se plaît...
Est-ce que ça te tente de prendre un verre avec moi ?
Ouais, avec plaisir, tu viens t'assoir avec nous ?
Allez !
Tu viens souvent ici non ?
Ouais, c'est un peu notre QG, avec les filles.
Je crois que je t'ai déjà croisée ici...
Tu crois ou t'en es sûr ?
Je crois que je suis sûr.
Ok, donc t'as l'air bien sûr de toi...
Je suis jamais sûr de moi quand je parle aux jolies filles, je sais pas ce qu'il se passe...
Attends, attends, tu l'as répétée celle-là ?
Ça se voit ?
Ouais !
Bah oui.
Mais franchement j'aime bien.
Non mais bien, mais c'est hyper bien Julien franchement bravo !
Ok moi j'y vais, allez ! Passez une bonne soirée, cassez-vous !
Genre tu sors pas avec nous toi ?
Non j'ai un mémoire à faire, cassez-vous !
Bon beh on y va hein...
Et c'est toi là ! Regarde ta vieille tête avec ton bandeau !
T'as vu la tronche de tes potes ? On en parle de tes potes toi ?
De mes potes à moi ?
Beh oui Michel, la tronche qu'il a avec sa moustache.
Bon écoutez, les gars ! Il faut que je vous dise un truc.
Voilà ! Je vais prendre mes billets, je vais me casser en Australie ! Il faut que je change de vie.
Vous êtes sérieux là ?
Non mais Zoé, ça fait mille ans que tu dis ça, t'as jamais pris tes billets.
Moi je t'écoute plus à force. C'est bon !
Ok, bon moi je vais chercher à boire.
Beh Assa non plus apparemment.
Mais non mais tu penses qu'en partant l'herbe elle va être plus verte ailleurs alors que c'est faux Zoé.
Téma Julien ! Tu vois le mec ? T'as vu un peu le regard, l'assurance !
Il a toutes ses chances ! Donc du coup Assa elle se fait draguer direct.
Lui, il a toutes ses chances ? C'est un vieux plouc !
Il est surdiplômé, je crois, c'est Gégé qui m'a dit ça.
D'accord mais s'il a des diplômes, qu'est-ce qu'il branle derrière un bar en fait ?
Mais t'es juste jaloux en fait ?
Beh non, parce que j'en ai rien à foutre.
Mais genre ! Genre ! MDR ! Genre ! Genre !
Tu pues le mensonge !
Wouah tu vas où là ? Tu fais quoi ?
C'est juste tu me casses les couilles à me chercher, c'est ridicule.
Mais elle te cherche et tu tombes dans le panneau aussi ! T'es con !
Tu vas voir qui c'est Raoul !
Ouais après je te cache pas que c'est cool de rencontrer des gens.
Des fois tu rencontres des gens super...
Excuse-moi il y a que ces deux bières ?
Deux secondes on discute là.
Ouais mais en fait nous on a soif.
Donc du coup on va prendre plus de bières !
Est-ce que je peux prendre du picon dans la mienne s'il-te-plaît !
Ça c'est un euro en plus ça.
Un euro ?
Ouais.
À la bonne heure, on va faire ça. On fait ça ok ?
T'étais là hier toi non ?
Je suis là tout le temps. C'est mon QG ici mec, t'es nouveau du coup ?
Euh nouveau, non. C'est mon deuxième jour.
Deuxième jour ?
Ouais.
Ça ça se fête ça ! Est-ce qu'on peut prendre quatre shots ?
Quatre !
C'est mon deuxième jour comme je t'ai dit.
Mec, on peut les prendre pour toi si tu veux les shots, on peut célébrer pour toi.
Ok vas-y on fait ça.
Allez, avec tout le temps qu'on passe ici...
Oui ! Il a dit oui ! Ok ça fera quatre shots ! Quatre shots quoi ?
Gingembre...
Gingembre ! On va prendre quatre shots gingembre !
On va prendre quatre pintes, est-ce que je peux prendre celle avec le picon s'il-te-plaît.
Et est-ce que tu peux prendre ces deux et les ramener là-bas.
Moi je vous rejoins, ok ?
Et je vais prendre le reste...
Il en manque deux !
Tu t'appelles comment ?
Romuald.
Martin ! C'est génial !
Ok !
Tu veux pas qu'on reprenne un autre shooter ?
Beh vas-y, chaud.
Vas-y t'es chaud, je vais demander.
Ah ouais, et ton frère il a grave kiffé la petite leçon cette aprem.
Et je suis hyper fière. Franchement, joli travail.
Hé beh dis donc Assa, ça mouille ça mouille.
Attention ça coule sur le parquet ma soeur.
Vas-y vas chier Zoé t'es pas marrante.
Non mais arrête Assa, ça se voit que tu le kiffes.
Hé ! Hé regarde-moi, je suis pas conne !
Et par contre là il est vraiment en train de discuter avec la gente féminine là.
C'est magnifique.
Enfin, hier il faisait pareil jusqu'au drame.
Non mais hier il s'est planté, on a tous le droit de se planter en fait.
Ouais enfin là, on dirait une petite sorte de bébé qui fait ses premiers pas. Tu vois ?
Ou une espèce de Coquille Saint-Jacques qui sort de sa coquille mais sans la Saint-Jacques t'as vu ?
En fait c'est le béret que j'ai vu de loin.
J'ai vu le béret avant de te voir toi.
Il y a un côté Bonnie & Clyde qui est très intéressant.
Non mais je te jure, de loin, j'ai vu Bonnie,
Je me suis dit, il est où Clyde ? Il manque Clyde, il est où ?
C'est ça ! C'est ça, tu as saisi ma personne.
Euh... On va finir par les boire ces shoots ou...?
Ouais. Euh... Là pour le coup c'est moi qui est en train de parler mais oui j'arrive.
Ok.
Ok...
Je crois qu'elle a l'air de s'impatienter là ta copine...
De quoi ?
Ta copine !
Non. Non, non c'est la copine de ma soeur donc elle peut s'impatienter, il y a aucun souci.
Et toi t'es venue seule ici ?
Ah non, je suis avec des potes dehors.
Ok, et bien je te libère, tu peux les rejoindre.
Ah merci !
Mais par contre tout à l'heure on boit un verre ensemble ok ?
Ok, ça marche.
Je vais les rejoindre, sinon elles vont péter un câble.
Et juste, t'étais pas là hier déjà ?
Si...
Je suis passé en coup de vent, très rapide.
Ok.
Vas-y à toute Bonnie.
À toute.
Mais je lui plais c'est sûr.
Ah là là ! Il a discuté avec un petit cul trois minutes il est au bout de sa vie.
Hé! Hé ! Une de plus, tu te serais fait tej comme une merde mon frère.
On a frôlé la catastrophe.
Chouchou ! Je suis hyper fière de toi !
Franchement je suis trop fière de toi, je te kiffe.
Vas-y.
Et les shooters tout le monde !
Allez ! Allez !
Bonne année !
Et c'est quoi ça ? C'est bon ça wesh ?
T'attends quoi ?
De quoi j'attends quoi ?
Beh tu me plais.
Je t'envoie des grands feux verts depuis des jours.
Encore pire cette aprèm.
Et toi beh...
Beh tu fais rien...
Je fais rien mais c'est normal, comment tu veux que je sache que je te plais ?
Arrête.
Ça se voit.
Invite-moi dehors.
Là maintenant ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Euh... Je vais fumer une clope, ok ?
Venez on prend un snap avant.
En despee, deux secondes.
Vous êtes sérieux ou quoi les gars ? Mais pas du tout je veux pas avec toi.
Beh Zoé !
Mais je t'aime bien mais voilà.
Non je déconne.
Mon amour.
Mais qu'elle est belle ! Mais qu'elle est belle ! Mais qu'elle est belle !
Oh mais qu'elle est belle.